in the past 24 hours all the violence
and unrest we saw in occupied east
jerusalem has switched
to gaza israel is continuing to hit the
strip
with airstrikes 27 of people have been
killed
including nine children and israel's
defense minister has approved more
attacks
as well as the calling up of about 5 000
reserve soldiers
meanwhile hamas and palestinian armed
groups have been firing hundreds of
rockets themselves into southern israel
two women killed in fact in the city of
ashkelon in israel
giving rise to all of this of course was
monday's violence in occupied east
jerusalem
when israeli forces stormed al-aqsa
mosque compound hundreds of palestinians
were wounded some of them
hit by those rubber-coated steel bullets
in the eyes so our coverage team as they
have been the last few days nida ibrahim
in ramallah occupied west bank harry
fawcett
has moved from occupied east jerusalem
to southern israel this is i believe
harry
as close as you can get safely to the
gaza barrie offense
well yes as close as we can get for now
the israeli
police checkpoint on the main road here
uh they
didn't let us get any closer than this
so we're a couple of kilometers away
from that border fence uh we're south of
ashkelon where there
and uh indeed where that very very large
barrage was fired a little earlier on uh
on tuesday uh that barrage hamas says
consisted of 137 rockets fired within
five minutes so that is a a major uh
firing of of heavy ordnance at these two
towns
and it seems to have uh swamped the iron
dome symptom
system to some extent i think i just had
another interception in the distance
there
um and we have now got this confirmation
that a house was hit
in ashkelon and two women were killed uh
as you say the airstrikes continue
inside gaza as well that death toll now
up to 27 including nine children
and the israeli military is talking
about one strike in particular on an
apartment building
in the center of gaza city in which the
palestinian-islamic jihad faction
said three of its fighters were killed
the israeli military and
islamic jihad have both confirmed that
one of them was a
rocket fire commander
and i think and that proceeded the the
very big
barrage that came in the other direction
they had hamas and the other factions
promised
to fire longer-range rockets if
residential areas
were hit and israel's airstrikes
unlikely to let up if we
go by what the israeli defense minister
is saying
indeed i mean is the israeli prime
minister as well on uh
monday night was saying that this was
going to be a forceful response
that it would take some time because as
far as he was concerned hamas had
crossed
red lines in firing long-range rockets
on jerusalem and that has been again
backed up by the defense minister his
political rival
benny gantz who says that the military
is calling up
000 reservists we're also hearing that a
major military
exercise that was scheduled for this
week has now been postponed
further so there is obviously
preparation and indeed
conducting of a major military operation
there is after what took place in
jerusalem where there were
a few concessions made jews not allowed
to get into the temple mount
uh the cancellation another interception
above us
the cancellation of uh the march
of flag-waving jewish nationalists
through the old city
it would have been there is i think some
political pressure on benjamin netanyahu
to exact a pretty strong
military response to uh what has been
coming out of gaza from hamas
and indeed we're seeing that borne out
in the extensive nature
of that military action and the number
of deaths inside gaza
including nine children harry forza
reporting live from southern israel as
we heard there the interception of hamas
rockets whilst harry was on air will go
to ramallah now
nida ibrahim in the occupied west bank
what are you hearing from inside gaza
and indeed from
the likes of hamas and islamic jihad
they are vowing to continue um
their barrage of rockets against israel
they
the aksa sorry the assam brigades that
are hamas military wing has issued a
statement saying that
israel has crossed the old red lines
when it comes to
besieging what they said the al-aqsa
mosque compound
and they there is a lot of palestinians
here in the occupied west bank who
are in support of these rocket attacks
they say that the palestinian the
palestinian response needs to be
forced because israel only understands
that language
but also you have on the other hand
those palestinians who would say that
israel would ultimately have the upper
hand
when it comes to any military escalation
on the ground they are
more equipped with iron domes with the
with airs with the airplanes and the
latest military
equipment so there is a split we can say
in the street when it comes to how they
are perceiving
these uh rocket attacks from hamas uh
which eventually lead to israel
attacking gaza and civilians there nina
what i'm about to ask you is quite
fundamental to the whole gaza story but
i think it's worth
reminding our viewers when we talk about
airstrikes on the strip
tell our viewers about what that means
for people inside who can't go
anywhere
they do not have any place to go to they
don't have shelters
and usually these attacks happen
in inhabited areas we've seen some of
the targets
or some of the israeli airstrikes
targeting open fields and also
resistance
uh uh targets but also there are
civilians that are in and around those
uh hamas
military fields and such so
there there are really no places for
them to go
and they um some of them were telling us
that they have to open the windows
because they can't afford having the
glass shattered from
the heavy sounds that are usually that
usually follow the
rockets hitting the ground so
or excuse me the air strikes hitting the
ground so it is
really a dire situation and this is why
many palestinians would tell you
that it is the civilians in gaza who pay
the price for any escalation
even if it starts in occupied east
jerusalem
yeah important for us to to remember all
of those facts they thank you nida
ibrahim
in ramallah now